so many of you have been asking me to
discuss the Elysian Fields but that in
itself would be an extremely short video
so I feel like making a video discussed
in the different regions located in the
Greek underworld would be far more
useful and insightful when a soul passes
through the gates of Hades they agree
today three judges of the underworld a
coasts Minos and Rhadamanthus who
essentially decide which part of the
underworld they will be sent to although
in most cases Tartarus wasn't considered
as part of the underworld
those who'd committed unspeakable crimes
would be thrown into the fiery pit
located deep beneath Hades Rhadamanthus
was the ruler of the region known as
Elysium which did occur by several other
names and I'm sure you may be more
familiar with including the Elysian
Fields and Elysium planes once one was
here they would enjoy a peaceful
afterlife devoid of any labor and
punishment however gained an entry to
this part of the underworld was far from
easy as it was reserved for the
favorites of the gods and those who had
achieved greatness an immense
recognition most of Elysium was made up
of demigods and heroes but normal people
could still make it here with one of the
most famous examples being Socrates who
gained recognition through philosophy in
silently sim there's a set of islands
known as the Isles of the Blessed all
are fortunate Isles when a soul had been
sent to Elysium they were given the
choice as to whether they wished to stay
in Elise him or be reborn
it was then considered a great
achievement if a soul was reborn and
sent to Elysium in three times that saw
will then be sent to the Isles of the
Blessed well they would live in a total
paradise much like a god now for those
who had not achieved great things but
who had also not committed any
significant crimes they would then be
sent to the asphodel Meadows this would
serve as somewhat of a happy medium and
often those who did not fit anywhere
else within the underworld would be sent
to these meadows the mourning field was
an area reserved for those who had
wasted their time loving someone who did
not reciprocate their feelings to
summarize it was an area full of the
brokenhearted and those who are
unfortunate enough to have their love
rejected the ancient Greeks did not look
at death as the end of one's existence
but unless you were lucky enough to
enter Elysium or the Isles of the
Blessed then the afterlife was somewhat
meaningless as your soul had no real
influence or purpose left the soul would
linger as a reminder that the dead once
existed but despite this there was still
a strong emphasis placed in the Greeks
to honor the dead to avoid punishment
from the gods and goddesses the Greek
underworld had a place for every type of
soul and
fully this explanation of the different
regions has been somewhat useful if you
have any thoughts and ideas on Elysium
or the Greek underworld as a whole you'd
like to share then please do so in the
comments below as always I've been your
host mythology in fiction explained
[Music]